Dr. Connors, the Hammer Ball on the RIF machine, the all-night program, it's my understanding that it is DNA repair, because you explained to me how that works.
So no, the Hammer Ball that said that you're doing your hall light program, it is not just DNA repair.
Matter of fact, I don't have DNA repair in most people's, I have that program based upon your cancer.
So that's based upon known frequencies for your cancer, frequencies based upon what we found that we believe the cause of your cancer is and your hits on your skin.
Okay, thank you. So it's not just DNA repair, so I would, you know, and I don't remember if I have DNA repair at yours at all.
So if you do feel inclined to run that DNA repair program during the day, for sure do so if you have time.
Okay, all right. What is the one, oh, then it's program specifically for me and my type of cancer for the night.
Yes, it is.
And the new Hammer Ball is more effective.
The new Hammer Ball.
I thought they have a new.
I do have a crystallized Hammer Ball, but is that the word you're talking about?
Right, that's the one that I have.
Oh, yeah, you could use that. I don't, you know, do I think that crystallized Hammer Ball is more effective?
I don't know. I have one. I've a bit experimenting with it. I'm not completely convinced that it's more effective or not.
But if you have one, use it.
I didn't, I personally didn't know the difference.
Yeah, but I'm using it.
Yeah, I didn't either. That's why we don't push it. They're more expensive. And I just haven't, you know, I try things and I'm not convinced that it's a lot better yet.
So.
Thank you. Thank you.